our next speaker
is for is from minnesota
and she plays ice hockey a lot of you
know i'm an ice hockey player too and i
appreciate that
so my real question for aaron is do you
do other minnesotan things like curl
because if you play hockey and you curl
then you know we've got to hang out more
and
go do ice sports so with that
please welcome aaron to the stage
okay so i think i'm on okay sorry
uh here we go here we go um so i think
my screen share is also working
um my name is aaron liddell um
i work at a company called h2oai
and i'm going to talk about automatic
machine learning
in our with h2o today
um here's a little overview of what
we're going to talk about today so i'm
just going to do a quick
um this is only a 20 minute talk so i'm
going to just do a very high level
um overview of what h2o is and what auto
auto ml or automatic machine learning is
and then i'm going to tell you a little
bit about
the h2o automl algorithm
which is inside of a h2o package
um so first if you're not
familiar with h2o um you can just
get it from crayon the package is called
h2o and
essentially what it is is like uh it's a
machine learning package
um you could call it a machine learning
platform because it kind of
it contains a bit more than just
algorithms
it's it's a whole distributed data
processing
framework as well so but just
at a high level so it's a bunch of
machine learning algorithms that are
distributed meaning that they
they run in parallel on your machine you
can also
make a cluster of machines where they
run across many machines if you have
very very large data
all the algorithms are written in java
but
most data scientists are either are
python users so we have an api in r in
python
um that's how you would probably use it
just the r
package uh one of the the things that
is sort of unique about h2o is that we
can
export the models as java code which is
helpful if you're trying to
productionize models
that's also not the only way that you
can save models you don't have to
deal with anything java if that's not
something you want to deal with
you can do pretty much everything in our
including productionize the models
in r exclusively if you like um
and it's meant to be compatible with
sort of big data platforms like hadoop
and spark
but for the most part i see just people
using it on their laptop so it's just
like a normal r package so
you it's it's really designed for very
very large data sets
big data sets but um you can use it on
tiny data sets you can use that any size
data sets
and it's just a matter of like what
hardware you want to use
to um to execute
okay so just a bit more about the
package we have
supervised and unsupervised machine
learning algorithms
pretty much just the the popular ones
that you would want to use like gradient
boosting machine
random forest deep neural networks glms
stacked ensembles also have a wrapper
for xg boost which is another gbm
um all of these uh except for
xgboost are written from scratch um by
us
in java in a distributed fashion so
that's kind of one of the differences
between
a package like h2o and a package like uh
carrot or
tiny models which are really more of
like a
a unifying layer on top of um
other r packages so that's that's sort
of one key difference between those two
but for the most part we
have the same goals of just having a
unified interface to a bunch of
machine learning algorithms and all of
the functionality that goes along with
machine learning like
cross validation grid search random
search variable importance
um model evaluation metrics like msc
auc log loss etc and then
plots um okay
so that's just a quick intro
to uh h2o um and then
let me just say a little bit about what
is automatic machine learning if you're
not familiar
so because this is kind of a let's say
a not well defined term um i think it's
it's better to talk about what are some
of the goals and features of automl
rather than to focus on trying to
define that um succinctly so
i think one of the one of the goals
really with automl is just to train the
best model in the least amount of time
so by that i mean time in terms of
actual computation time so how long is
it going to take you to train the model
once you press go
and then the other aspect of that which
is actually
um you know more addressed by automl
is how much time it takes you to set up
the
experiment or the training and by that i
mean you know
usually you write a whole bunch of code
that's like data pre-processing code
then the modeling code then the model
tuning code a model selection code and
just
lots of um code being written
um and so one of the the goals of automl
is to sort of
basically wrap a function around that
whole process and just
expose the parameters that are um
you know the basic building blocks of
what machine learning is you need a
training set
you need to decide what which column in
the training set are you trying to
predict
um you might want to decide like which
metrics you're interested in uh you
you don't have to necessarily pick
beforehand but
like if you're trying to maximize auc
for example in a binary classification
problem that's one example
and then essentially the only other
thing you need to tell an automl tool is
like
how long do you want it to run for so
really trying to
reduce like the human effort and
expertise required
in machine learning i think that's one
of the let's say goals of automl
and um also we're trying to give you
models that would probably be
better than what you could do on your
own now that's not
true of every single data scientist out
there um
it's for the most part humans are still
able to beat automl systems like if
you're a very
sophisticated data scientist who's been
practicing for 10 years or more and you
really
know all of the algorithms super well
and all of the data domains super well
um you could probably still beat every
auto ml system
out there so this is really just
for you know let's say the average or
even better than average data scientists
hopefully
you'd still get better models using an
automotive tool and then one of the last
things
um that i think is is nice about automl
is that it can
increase reproducibility so you really
have just this one simple function
it's easy to use you can get your
collaborators to use it
um it's easy to use by people that are
not sophisticated machine learning
people so
that kind of increases your ability to
collaborate with
with people let's say in a scientific
discipline i think it also is very
useful to
to just establish a baseline for any
problem but
in particular if you're you know a
scientist
trying to apply machine learning in a
new way one of the best things you can
do is just run an automl tool and just
see
kind of where you're at and then you try
to work up from there
okay so the um some of the aspects of
automated machine learning well
when we talk about automating machine
learning we're really just talking about
what are the aspects of machine learning
and then we have to automate all those
pieces
so that would include things like
anything related to data preparation
you know we'd like to automate um that's
a bit
that's actually quite a lot harder than
the middle part which is
just the models like automating model
generation is pretty straightforward um
you still have to decide the hard part
about that is
how to allocate your time so if you only
have an hour
or you only have a certain amount of
time how do you decide
where best to apply the work
you probably want to start with models
that you think are good or
will be good uh or algorithms that you
think would be good and then
certain settings so that the real task
there and the real task of any automated
machine learning tool is more about
prioritization of what we should try
first
rather than you know something that it's
not anything that somebody
couldn't write the code for it's just uh
it's hard to prioritize
um when you're given a time frame and
then if your goal is really to get the
best model with the least
the best model just overall in general
like one of the things that you can do
is
is to create ensembles from the models
that you generated so
uh when you do ensembling it generally
improves performance
um there's there's a few drawbacks of
ensembles which are like
uh one it could possibly take more time
to generate predictions
at the end um and depending on your use
case
that might be you know something you
can't have or
maybe it is um so we just let people
decide whether or not they want that as
part of their
process but if your goal really is
performance above
all else model performance then you
should probably be ensembling
okay um here's some different
uh aspects of uh automated machine
learning in more detail
so with data pre-processing by that
things that could be included in that
category would be imputation
one-hot encoding standardization um
different other types of encodings of
categorical features so there's
there's all sorts of different ways that
you can encode categorical
categorical features and a lot of it
depends on like let's say how many
features there are whether or not sorry
how many categories there are
and whether or not some of those
categories are extremely rare
like there's a lot of things to consider
when you choose your
encodings and so you know a good automl
tool
should try to optimize that and then
this could also
for the data pre-processing section we
could also just
do feature selection or future
extraction stuff like that
um for model generation there's lots of
different ways like
a popular way to generate a bunch of
models is just a grid search or a random
search
um there's also a technique called
bayesian hyper parameter optimization
that i won't
talk about but it's another method for
generating models and tuning models
and then for ensembles um the type of
ensembling that i generally do is called
stacked ensembles or super learning
but there's another one called ensemble
selection it also works well
and it really just depends on the type
of models that you're using
um in the ensemble which one of those
will probably
do better um okay
so and if you're not familiar with
automl
or what what software is out there
and how do you choose software
essentially it all boils down to like
what kind of data you have
do you have tabular data that's what i'm
going to talk about today that's
probably the most common type of data
and there's a whole set of automl
techniques for that
and then there's kind of a whole other
set of techniques for
image classification or text
classification related to automotive
and typically with those types of data
you end up using deep neural networks so
there's a whole
field of automl specific to the neural
networks
generally referred to as neural
architecture search but it can also
involve other things so i'm not going to
talk about that but if you're confused
about the different types
of automl i can recommend that you read
this blog post
that i wrote i think almost two years
ago now
okay so just check my time i have
a few minutes left six minutes so let's
talk about h2o automl
so here's the um the same slide that i
had before but i'm
highlighting the sort of our our
technique as a subset of all the
possible techniques out there so right
now we do
some basic data preprocessing and i
think in the next
uh version of h203 332 were
i you know i actually have been
promising this for the last couple of
versions but
i think for real this time we're going
to get um
automated target encoding for
categorical features in there and that's
going to be
a huge uh bonus to anyone who has
especially high cardinality categorical
features
i think that's going to help a lot um in
terms of models what we do is just
essentially for each algorithm that we
have we do a random search
and then we individually tune the models
um using cross validation and then once
we have the models we do
two stacked ensembles at the end um
so so why do we do this approach well
um with stacking so
i guess sort of working backwards when i
when i designed this system i knew that
i wanted to do stacking because i know
that that's the best way to get the best
models generally so then
um in order to to create a good stacked
ensemble you need kind of a diverse
selection of
models to go in there so one way to sort
of generate
a diverse set of models is to do a
random search
because then you know that randomness
generates diversity and
um basically stack ensembles do well
when the
individual models inside like what we
call the base models or the base
learners
are individually strong and they make
uncorrelated errors meaning
they fail sort of in different ways so
that's why we want to put like a deep
neural network
and a random forest and a gbm and
etc so that way um
that's kind of how the stacked ensemble
works i'm not going to go into a whole
lot of detail about that but
just keep that in mind so that's kind of
our approach there's other approaches by
other tools like
that are based on different techniques
for example um
genetic algorithms um bayesian
optimization
um etc so there's there's different
techniques that people use
and um this is just
ours okay so this is just sort of the
overview
um yeah basic data pre-processing
we train the random grid we tune the
models we have the two stacked ensembles
and then what we sort of get back with
after running this function is something
that we call the leaderboard
and i'll say what that is in a minute
but first i just want to show you what
the code looks like
because as are people that's probably
what you're here for
and so now you have it you have a one
function
um called h2o.automl and
essentially like i said at the beginning
the the very basic things that you need
to
provide are just what is your training
set
what is the column that you're trying to
predict and then like how long do you
want to run it for so
here we're running it for 10 minutes
then we're going to take a look at the
leaderboard
and see what we get generally run longer
than 10 minutes but
um you know maybe an hour or four hours
or
however long you um so
what the leaderboard is is basically
just a
data frame and in the first column we
have just the name of the model or the
model id
so these are all just models that are in
memory and you can access all of them
you can look at their hyper parameters
etc
but just to make things concise we we
just put the model id and then we sort
by
uh performance metrics and for binary
classification
by default we'll sort by cross-validated
auc so you'll see all the models
that we've trained on there we see the
stacked ensembles winning
that's pretty common um then we see a
few xg boosts
and etc down the line and so
how do these tools really do compare to
humans so i brought that up before so
like i said i think if humans have
enough time
they can beat the the auto ml tools
however
if it's really kind of like a short time
period like so kaggle had this one day
well let's say eight hour kaggle
competition
and um and basically uh
you know all the automl tools were
winning so that's unusual for kaggle
because
um you know if you have a two-month
competition people spend a lot of time
on feature engineering they
are very creative and they come up with
all these things and
uh they're able to win but with uh with
just a one day competition like i was
just able to run an h2 automl
for i think it was 100 minutes
um and i got eighth place in the
competition so i
literally basically did nothing i just
loaded the data set
ran it and then submitted my uh result
so um that's yeah so
in a short time frame i think um if
you're training models every day
like this is something that can
immediately help you
and then if you want to learn more i
finally
got around to publishing a paper about
h2o automl uh just last month
it's the tool has been out there for
about three years
um you know i spent a lot of time on
documentation and things like that and
not so much time on a paper but i did
finally
write one so if you want to read more
about the algorithm and see how it
scales
i did a study from like data sets of 10
000 rows all the way up to 100 million
rows
and that's not a single machine by the
way so we are
very able to scale um well basically
that's that's why
uh you know building an auto ml tool on
a library like h2o
is was appealing to me because the base
models themselves or the underlying
models are quite fast
so i only have one minute so i'm just
going to leave you with a few links
the last one is a talk that i just gave
at the usar
last month and this is all about
responsibility
uh of of data scientists so the title
was like responsible
automation and like how do basically how
do we be
responsible humans when we're building
these autumn automl tools and just
machine learning tools in general so
there's a lot of discussion about
interpretability and algorithmic
fairness and stuff like that so i think
i'm out of time so i will just
leave you with some contact info and a
shout out to our leads
we're just going to stop there cool
thanks jared
thank you for speaking and yes notice uh
the
the strong our lady's presence here
there's always been a good showing thank
you all for coming thank you everyone
for coming